the announcement confirmed the rumors
Egypt will hold a presidential election
in December several months ahead of
schedule
an opportunity for change said president
Abdul fattah al-sisi who stopped short
of declaring his candidacy although it's
a foregone conclusion for most Egyptians
it comes at a time of economic crisis
that keeps on biting Egyptians have had
it harder than usual as of late and
there's anger on the streets
the price of food and basic Goods
continues to soar and the middle class
that have had to dip into their savings
to get by is gradually becoming poorer
the Egyptian pound has lost more than 50
percent of its value against the US
dollar in the last 18 months and there's
a shortage of foreign currency CeCe has
urged Egyptians to be patient arguing
that the combined consequences of the
pandemic the global economic crisis and
the war in Ukraine are to blame
but many point the finger at corruption
poor management and the waste of money
on new projects that are seen as
unnecessary the vote is not expected to
bring any real change but it's crucial
to give CC legitimacy before imposing
more economic hardship on the country
the international monetary fund is
demanding reforms before releasing some
three billion dollars the U.S froze 85
million of its yearly military aid
citing human rights concerns and Saudi
Arabia is demanding Egypt to comply with
the IMF before approving any further Aid
CC has no real competition opposition
candidates say they are regularly
intimidated by Security Services and
don't have real popular support
it's been more than 12 years since a
popular Uprising toppled president Jose
Mubarak and made way for Cece's rise to
power
many Egyptians say they are
disillusioned about the Integrity of the
upcoming vote about 41 percent
registered voters cast their ballots in
the last election five years ago the
turnout this time will show just how
much Egyptians are willing to listen to
their leader
Al Jazeera
make sure to subscribe to our channel to
get the latest news from Al Jazeera